now let's be honest Trump is the first
president to confront China which is
increasingly wealthy increasingly
aggressive largest standing army in the
world no one else has done it like him
and now there may be a major fight
brewing with Mexico over trade NAFTA and
the wall who's gonna pay for it my next
guest is at the center of it all and the
US Trade Representative bobwhite Heiser
might not be a household name but you're
not gonna want to miss any of this he
joins us exclusive thanks for being back
with us so we read that now on this
issue with NAFTA renegotiation all these
deals I keep hearing the scuttlebutt
about all these great new deals are
going to start that there's been a snag
in the negotiations and it was reported
in reuters washington post that there
was a call between the president and the
mexican president Pena Nieto and it
ended and kind of some type of testing
man or I guess the snag or the holdup
was about who's gonna fund the wall I
just want to play something for you my
radio listeners today chimed in on this
topic of whether it matters if Mexico
pays or if it's an indirect payment
let's listen I'm totally in support of
the president if he can bring in much
more revenue bringing billions of
dollars and use those funds to pay for
the wall it's the heart of that deal I
always expected my tax dollars the face
of the wall so mr. ambassador doesn't
seem like the hardcore Trump supporters
care about the wall so why should that
be a snag here it seems like the
president has played this really smartly
as a negotiating matter I mean first of
all the wall is kind of out of my lane I
stay in my lane we have to have a wall
beyond that I stay in my lane and my
lane my lane is really about trying to
get new deals it's trying it's trying to
to reverse a very bad trend that we've
had for a long long time in the trade
area the president ran on this he feels
strongly about it when I talk to him is
kurz ranchers farmers that's it it's
wages and it's jobs and I think if we if
we renegotiate that deal if we good a
good deal with Mexico and hopefully with
Canada if that's possible
we're gonna find more jobs the biggest
holdup seems to be about auto
manufacturing and that's where the
lion's share of our trade deficit with
Mexico is I would shock to just read
today that 77% of Mexican of
manufactured vehicles that were exported
came to the United States now that's
because there's no tariffs on those
because of NAFTA correct correct and
what will a potential deal look like
regarding that type of imbalance the
biggest part of the problem between the
two countries and from a trade point of
view is that Mexico has an industrial
policy which is a smart one it's
designed to get auto companies to move
to Mexico and then ship to the US you
say seventy seven percent for some
companies it's even higher and a lot of
these are companies with very little
products that are made in America so
they're low US content and the kind of
thing we're looking at is to have a
better balance to have a higher regional
content but also a u.s. content and to
reorganize the way we keep track of
which is which the president's objective
is we have to get more jobs back to
America we have to reduce the deficit
and that will ultimately put pressure on
wages and wage wage again global trade
which is a big big publication in the
global trade arena they say that critics
will say that advanced economies have
been steadily reducing the share of jobs
in manufacturing and that's really
accounting for a lot of the job losses
in the United States you can you can
nail some of them to NAFTA but most of
it is because of improving approving in
productivity technology changing so
we're steadily moving away from those
types of manufacturing jobs what do you
say to that the greatest economies in
the world right now are the United
States they're China they're Germany and
they're Japan who says Germany and Japan
don't have basically a lot of
manufacturing now as a percentage it's
ranking perhaps but those are still
great jobs very important jobs and they
spin-off wealth
to thousands and millions and millions
of other people who serve the people who
do the manufacturing so to me it's
complete nonsense to say that we don't
need manufacturing so if we have a sixty
billion dollar seventy billion dollar
trade deficit met with Mexico we have
mmm eight times that maybe with China
last year was the biggest trade deficit
first year the Trump administration that
we've ever had now you have to decide by
the administration by April about what
you're gonna do with Chinese aluminum
imports you have concern of dumping you
know under market price goods and
they're now saying well we're gonna wait
we could retaliate on your agricultural
our gum coming into the United States
feeds livestock and so there's a trade
war light Heiser droppers start a trade
war it's gonna be a nightmare and you
say the response that we're going to
start a trade war is nonsense we have a
very very imbalanced relationship with
China and once again it's not based on
basic economics it's based on an
industrial policy this is a country that
has a centrally driven kind of an
economy they they take technology they
subsidize they use access to their own
markets and create an enormous amount of
wealth and in imbalance with the United
States not based on basic economics a
lot of people I hear say well the
president doesn't really know the nuance
of policy he'll just get on the phone
with someone and will blow up the
negotiations or he doesn't really follow
the the nitty-gritty of things like
trade or military policy you're in all
these meetings with President Trump on a
on a weekly basis sometimes a daily
basis given what's going on I know you
can't reveal what he says but you can
tell us does he get these concepts look
at if you look what President Trump said
when he was 35 years old and follow it
to where he says what he's saying right
now it's the same thing he understands
the issues when I'm in these meetings it
is it is a very strong give-and-take
from a variety of people with interest
the president is beyond engaged he cares
about jobs and wages politics never
comes up and when he's not thinking
about job
wages its wages and jobs this is what
this is what he thinks about we really
appreciate your coming on spending some
time Thank You Laura this is this is an
extremely important issue you're one of
the very few people that is actually
pushing it and part of the reason is
because it is complicated but it's
extremely important I'm a moderate if
had a chance to come out here and talk
about it ambassador light eyes are
thanks so much thank you